Donald Trump is the Republican nominee  for president in 2024 will he vote for  him  somebody else I'd prefer more  okay  you know what I can tell you is um I  have every confidence that the  Republican party is going to sort out  leadership all my focus has been on the  midterm elections and it'll stay that  way for the next 20 days but after that  we'll be thinking about the future  ours and the Nations and yeah so first  of all he's sort of saying I might be  running I mean to some degree what Mike  Pence is saying is there might be  someone on the ballot I prefer like  myself when he says we're going to be  thinking about our future and the  Nations he's saying I'm going to be  thinking about what I want to do in 2024